hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
Alan Saucon and we have the pleasure of
sitting down for my good friend Lisa
leek dinger hello hi Alan so nice to
have you it's a pleasure to be here it's
a very short little it is happy women
today so this is a gonna be a little
shorty we're gonna talk a little bit
about emotions behavior a little bit
about our future with machines we'll do
that for a little while we have another
live stream coming up in about a half
hour so I'll be fun as well so Lisa
maybe talk to us a little bit about your
background while you find it so
interesting to be involved in this space
sure I love to from what I understand I
think everyone has a core Drive and
motivators that allow them to take
certain behaviors and actions and then
your mentality comes after that
following that most of the time and so
there's some primary drivers and if
human beings can get in touch with that
then they have the ability to express
that in various different ways with more
clarity in their life so this is
something that I've always thought about
in how it relates to our social
interactions how it relates to our
interactions in in nature how it relates
to our interactions in an artificial
simulation as well and so I think it all
has to do with communication how we're
able to understand how our cells are
communicating with with each other how
that impacts us and how we're able to
bring that to another level with our
communication with other people so yes I
say the word communication a lot because
I think often we forget about this and
so this is what brought me to understand
this through the vessels of what I
studied which would be psychology
human-computer interaction and human
capital development yeah the core drive
that's within every single person and
how the communication and the behavior
within our own introspective ability can
then we can then analyze and better
figure out how to guide ourselves to
what we are driven towards maybe do it
in a more in a mini case a more moral
way a more ethical way less judgmental
way and so then these are things that
you've been uncovering and are now
starting to figure out how to apply them
to our relationship with machines
correct I'm not the first one there's
many people that for several years
before I was even born in fact
contemplated what is what is going to be
the the paradigm in worldview that is
adopted worldwide when we start
interacting with with robots with
intelligent artificial agents which
right now looks like something like lark
that was one of the first apps that
tried to get you something like food or
something transportation interaction
applications a lot of interest in things
like syria alexa and what's come out of
that has been human beings association
to some emotion derived from and
delivered from these these systems right
so the human being essentially is
developing these systems for different
purposes and I think it's quite curious
that we've developed these systems to
kind of model us through another vessel
that is not human so you can make that
connection there's so many different
ways I can go here though hmm the
interesting thing that I want to focus
on is that this this morning I had a
meeting
x2 AI and they're figuring out what
personality to build and if they should
have one psychological AI coach or if
they should have many for different
purposes and also Hanson robotics has
Sophia right the the humanoid robot what
should that be purposed for and what are
all of these other robotics machines and
and other essentially systems and
independent like agents for humans to
communicate to get what they want in for
fulfill what it is that is driving and
motivating them so this is kind of where
it's at so yeah you're explaining it
really well I think so so there is so
there's the human driven desire to have
some sort of behavior fulfilled through
a robot or through an artificial
intelligence and then the way that we
interact with that with the design of it
is kind of what you're up to
so what are maybe some of the you know
you just have this conversation today is
what are what is sort of the consensus
right now should there be multiple
psychologists working with the robot in
the being and like how are they trying
to help make that human interaction work
out with the robot right so back to what
you said about ethics and morals and
values it's highly dependent and based
on the demographic and psychographic of
the target audience that it's being
produced for so if you're trying to
create something it's good to know the
audience and what you're optimizing for
right if it's if it's meant to be
partnered with let's say something like
uber health or Werkheiser then it's
going to go through some kind of
approval fda and then there's gonna be
certain limitations that are necessary
to protect the client and the patient so
once you understand the limitations and
constraints or if there are no
limitations and constraints that that's
when you go more into research and
development
which can be really fun but also quite
concerning because what we're doing is
having you know humans just tests all
this out without knowing exactly the
long-term response or redesign that
these interactions were having are going
to have on the human now some people say
that's fine we're going to change
anyways let's just do it like this and
other people say this is a horrible
terrible thing and you know people will
not like Silicon Valley in the future
because of these things that came out of
it when we were just experimenting and
pushing these forward to the world
economy so ethically I'm glad you
brought that up the ethical design is
extremely important for me when I
consider all of this so let's maybe
unpack two things first thing is
tailoring the interaction towards
different demographics of people and
then two is figuring out how to best
program ethics into the interaction what
it what are you thoughts about yeah
that's tough yeah it's a whole big
unpack it takes us hours it's hot yeah
it's fascinating most certainly when the
human species have hasn't really come to
an agreement or figured that out as well
yeah and so due to that one conversation
I had this week I'm saying that's why
you need to create all these different
you know products and tools in in this
area for different demographics that are
specifically tailored for them right so
so that match their their worldview yeah
yeah so we have a couple things that are
fairly decently set in Civilization thou
shalt not kill seems to be a fairly
common thread across a
large percentage of our world generally
generally and so that that can be a
fairly hopefully easy one for our
interaction with with robots and then we
have to figure out all the other ones
about you know cheating about stealing
about her injuring about all that when
is it okay to do so but for the
organizations that are actually building
this into the world today they're there
how concerned are they about this
interaction with humans and how what
what are the conversations that are
going on with all of these different
psychologists and behavioral scientists
about figuring out how to you said you
know tailoring it to certain
demographics is important what are the
other sort of pieces that are going into
the puzzle you can have something that's
that's extremely accurate though not
relevant for instance a lot of the data
that corporations like to use for their
next quarter to maximize like on the
return and financially can be quite
accurate now all this information is
necessary for the systems that are set
up for corporations to run as it is now
right and so you have this entire new
workforce that's coming in that is
expecting different things and demanding
different things not to say millennial
but people that are more health
conscious adopting different models of
open communication and transparency and
it's in fact unavoidable given the tools
that were using for communicating in
business and so when you're optimizing
for getting a very accurate reading
right it's not always relevant because
what is relevant are all of these new
intangibles that we don't know
specifically how to measure
it's very difficult to optimize for
human human emotion or human you know
empathy or a certain state you know you
have trait specific we have personality
tests right but state specific what what
is making that state
how can you sustain it and how does that
help us in in terms of a human you know
capital development let's say in the
workforce yeah so I think a lot of the
conversations that are occurring are if
we're using all of these different tools
in parallel to this new generation or
this new quest and and desire for this
optimization even with you know let's
say older generations in the workforce
how are we going to smoothly introduce
this new form of Governments let's say
and how are we going to do the research
that's necessary to maintain integrity
and quality and all these things when
people are interacting with these new
systems so a lot of a lot of it you
wouldn't imagine when you're designing
these different personalities let's say
for an artificial intelligent even chat
bot that's interacting with you is well
at what point should they ask for your
information what's the privacy and
security what's the cryptographic
backing behind it how much should the
patient or client or or or no it is
happening behind the scenes yeah yeah
how much of a responsibility and
accountability does the service provider
have or does that go somewhere else so
yeah all of these things are still super
important yeah you nailed it
right there there was like so many
different things
sorry this is all this is of a lot of
what do you do as have these
conversations and try and figure out how
you it's such a good question is we
don't even know how to maximize a
empathic connection in a human to human
conversation let alone a human to
artificial being conversations so and
and and so we so the more that we have
conversations about how to figure that
out the more we can maybe translate that
to the human robot connection as well as
like you said figuring out when the even
something as simple as a chat bot would
ask the person that's using the chat bot
for more private information and what is
yeah this how transparent should the
organization be about the security of
that about how it's actually working how
much is it actually learning about you
how much is the information just pass it
along to the company or the order
there's so many variables there's
different purposes also for all this and
many people are getting on the bandwagon
but it's not it's not really necessary
for every kind of person and then group
across the planet though I do see it
will be mass adopted and implemented
into a lot of government and corporate
systems know maybe we should chat about
this then is that do you think that an
organization like Hanson or a different
organization that is working with robots
and artificial intelligent beings do you
think that that they should be the ones
that choose to the structure the cott
the way that the conversation is
happening between the human and the and
the artificial intelligence or should it
be potentially a conversation at the
federal level of the governments or even
at the United Nations level where do you
think that that stands that's a really
good question I think the way it's gone
so far is that subject matter experts in
you know neuroethics bioethics
you know macro games game theory you
know behavioral economics anyone that
has a good understanding of the human
design and economic design and not only
that all the other elements that are
essential I think what it is is a you
know collection of people that can
gather together and really discuss all
of these different aspects you know
there's even you said today's Women's
Day right even not what even is women
Women's Day I look like a woman you know
I have a sex in gender and sexual
identity right but how we how we decide
what a woman is still there's no common
consensus right so how to decide who
will have you know reign over what what
content is being delivered through a
robot or you know avatar or even through
a human it has a lot to do with
educating people so I think that's
really important yeah get people that
are well intentioned and get them
together and help answer these hard
questions yeah exactly and that's a lot
of what we do with simulation as we
bring really intelligent people into
these conversations and we try and
increase the amount of people across the
world that are having these tough
conversations and hopefully we can you
know figure out if it's gonna happen at
the company level the government level
the UN level but at what level are we
going to be having the tough discussions
and who's going to be making the
decisions and hopefully benevolent
decisions benevolent people so so you so
this is this is also something that I
think that we should chat about
especially on Women's Day so many women
are getting the PhDs in Psychology
nowadays I think it's over 75% of PhDs
are awarded to women now which is great
it's the thing that's a very it's very
aligned with what women care
it's people and so a lot and that's
generally speaking men are very much
more like logical ideas women are like
people and nourishment and nurturing so
I feel like we need more women to be a
part of the discussion about the human
robot conversation and interface how
what was that design gonna look like
yeah you've been my friend for some time
and I have to say that I disagree tell
me yeah less that I disagree I see
something now else that would be
beneficial you know in parallel so I
think often the typical stereotype of a
man is told you're a man you do this you
think this right yeah what I've seen and
and I think you know a lot of these
individuals as well is that what's
innately
or inherently a female trait essentially
can also live within the man
absolutely there's tenderness the
softness and if you look at really
strong men let's say in positions of
very very high power positions making
you know really crucial executive
decisions in fact I just met with Martin
Hellman and his wife Dorothy Hellman who
who were very essential in many of the
strategic decisions made in different
world wars and different you know policy
worldwide international policy he he is
a very strong human being and so is his
wife and you meet them and they have
this new book called the new Mac or
something like this and they speak to
this at great length to promote them but
I adored that was about it yeah
they speak to the importance of a man
like rekindling their their divinity and
tenderness as well and then operating
from that place of established anchored
stillness so absolutely when we talk
about this thing about women yes but
also I really think it's important that
what we see is happening is that men are
more embracing this you know allowed at
least in certain countries not all of
them other places still it does not
allow but let's say speak or in Silicon
Valley so we'll say this right very very
much embrace but other places in the
country now as well though I think women
also would benefit from being in tune
with this divine center just because
you're a woman
doesn't necessarily mean that you've
allowed all of these other seeds to
flourish right so I think absolutely
it's constant work to do something like
this and and to you know be very honest
and open with yourself and then so this
is part of the state that's necessary
for you to be coherent and have synergy
with yourself and then if you're able to
attune the human not to talk too much
energetics right but um it's a little
literally part of the decision-making
process and so if you're able to
cultivate the state of mastery within
yourself you're able to clearly see
things differently and at like the
thought leader level you have less
hesitation you're able to you know clear
the distractions from your mind I think
you know this you've got a pass in a
meditation and this is what that's one
tool you know to train yourself like
this and so bringing it back to you know
women and having women more more phd's
women I think having more PhDs or more
people in academia or rigorous science
that have developed the balance between
themselves would allow them to see
different vessels for research in fact
so god it's ya know how we came to that
that was per that was
perfectly said I think that was a really
good way to explain kind of where I also
am totally coming from that same place
as you I love how you explain that
that's really on point there's so much
within us that can come to flourishing
whether it is whoever it may be no
matter what your sex or gender is and in
order to maximize our own spirit it's
important to water and flourish these
different seeds within us to and to feel
like we are being our full authentic
being and that actually triggers a level
of energy and vibes that are just
unprecedented there's just there's no
going back to to to overthinking what
you are saying you just blow and you
just dance with it and we'll need more
of that in general inside of the the
conversation about the machine and human
interface and see if you have more
people optimizing for this and operating
at this level of clarity and and
functioning imagine these are the people
that are start starting to think
differently that are building these
tools exactly and that's exactly what we
need and that's this has been a little
taste of what the conversation this this
has been just a little tiny taste into
the conversation of emotions and
behavior and how to maximize the
connection between different
demographics different scenarios
different levels of security different
levels of transparency between the human
and the Machine and what we're gonna
build into the future I want to say you
know huge shout out to Lisa thank you so
much for joining us it's been such a
pleasure thank you thank you
I love her she's amazing I feel very
grateful she's all the way from Hong
Kong in San Francisco she's got a big
family here too that's trying to hold
her back for a couple of more days so
hopefully we can do something again soon
maybe we'll get a chance to host a
simulation live event yes together that
would be amazing I think everyone's very
interested in this conversation so
hopefully we can do that together
shout out to Ron Fargus thank you for
producing and directing guys at home if
you had a good time like subscribe
comment share the content as well where
I'm patreon and get exclusive benefits
for joining in with us thank you so much
and we'll see you again soon
[Music]
you